ein gigantischer reich verzierter bau
hoch in den pyrenäen
absolut erstaunlich dass so etwas dort
stich
die ruine einer forschungsanstalt mitten
in der russischen tundra
ein bizarrer der ein fenster in das
erste unseres planeten öffentlich
eine geheimnisvolle militärbasis in
niemandsland der kalifornischen wüste
als ob jene atom bombe eingeschlagen
wäre
und ein futuristisches beton labyrinth
in der nähe von brüssel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
die anlagen aufgegeben manche sind heute
lebensgefährlich verseucht
wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden sie
errichtet und warum wurden sie
aufgegeben
[Musik]
1 500 seelen ort mitten in den pyrenäen
direkt an der spanisch-französischen
grenze
in dem abgelegenen gebirgstal auf fast
1200 meter höhe steht dieses enorm lange
reich verzierte gebäude
absolut erstaunlich dass dort so was
steht es ist groß fast schon ein palast
und liegt mitten in den pyrenäen
[Musik]
drumherum gibt es nicht gerade viel
aus der entfernung könnte man das
gebäude für eine fabrik oder ein altes
kraftwerk hacken
doch tatsächlich ist es ein reich
verzierter dreistöckiger palast mit 356
fenstern um
156 türen
verteilt auf 250 meter länge
auf die idee muss man erstmal kommen
etwas so noble sun einem so abgelegenen
ort zu bauen das ist schon sehr
erstaunlich
diesen prachtbau eine mischung aus
klassizismus und hannover zu errichten
war enorm teuer
warum wurde er mitten in den bergen
gebaut um dann wieder aufgegeben zu
werden
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts gibt
es kaum verkehrsverbindungen durch die
pyrenäen zwischen frankreich und spanien
die gebirgskette erstreckt sich rund 430
kilometer in ost westlicher richtung es
gibt hier kaum straßen oder
eisenbahnstrecken ein großes hemmnis für
den handel zwischen spanien und
resteuropa die spanische regierung
beschließt daher eine bahntrasse durch
die berge zu bauen
[Musik]
die idee eine bahnlinie durch die
pyrenäen zu bauen war sehr reizvoll und
als sie dann gebaut wurde war das eine
gigantische leistung ein projekt
vergleichbar mit dem bau des
panamakanals mit vielen langen tunnel
und brücken da steckte jahrelange sehr
anspruchsvolle arbeit drin
[Musik]
der zentrale knotenpunkt der neuen trans
pyrenäen bahnstrecke ist der bahnhof vom
kann fragt
baubeginn 1921
doch der bau der trasse stellt die
ingenieure vor technische probleme
als in spanien ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts die ersten bahn strecken
gebaut wurden wählte man das breitspur
format mit
1668 mm
frankreich wiederum verwendet die
internationale normalspur mit einem maß
von
1435 mm
ein technisches team denn weder die
spurweite der schienen noch die
spurweite achsen der züge lassen sich
nachträglich ändern
spanische züge hatten eine andere spur
weiter als französische also braucht man
einen bahnhof der groß genug war die
französischen züge zu entladen und die
spanischen züge zu beladen und umgekehrt
die einzige lösung eine umladestation
von einer spurweite auf die andere
[Musik]
dafür braucht man viel platz daher die
dimensionen des bahnhofs kampf an
als der bahnhof 1928 fertiggestellt wird
ist er einer der größten und
höchstgelegenen bahnhöfe europas
sein spitzname lautet titanic der berge
durch den bau dieses riesigen bahnhofs
in den pyrenäen wurde eine neue
effiziente handelsroute nach frankreich
und in den rest europas geschaffen
fernanda sanchez morales ist
bürgermeister von kann frank
[Musik]
wie viel hier investiert wurde um diese
internationale bahnstrecke zu bauen
am 18 juli 1928 wird der bahnhof kam
frank von könig alfons von spanien
feierlich eröffnet der regent sagt die
pyrenäen gibt es nicht mehr
kann frank ist einer der größten
bahnhöfe europas er beherbergt unter
anderem den grenzschutz ein hotel
restaurants und rund 2.000 beschäftigte
[Musik]
spanien wähnt sich am ziel und glaubt
wieder zu den hauptakteuren europas zu
gehören
doch die geschichte macht den bourbonen
einen strich durch die rechnung
1929 kommt es zum größten börsencrash
der geschichte
1931 geht könig alfons ins exil und 1936
bricht der spanische bürgerkrieg aus der
rechtsgerichtete putschist general
franco lässt einen der haupttunnel die
nach kann frank führen zu machen um
waffenlieferungen an die republikanische
regierung zu verhindern der weg nach
frankreich und europa ist abermals
blockiert
der bahnhof von kann frank hatte das
große pech auf einer geopolitischen
bruchlinie zu liegen die tunnel wurden
zeitweilig gesperrt weil francos
regierung den schmuggel eindämmen wollte
ab 1936 kontrollieren francos schärfen
dem bahnhof ihr kommandant empfängt
adolf hitler in kaum frank franco will
hitlers unterstützung um republikaner
und kommunisten endgültig zu besiegen
für hitler ist es eine willkommene
gelegenheit seine neuesten waffen zu
testen vor allem kanzler und die
flugzeuge der noch jungen luftwaffe
1939 ist franco ein ziel er hat den
bürgerkrieg gewonnen und ist das neue
staatsoberhaupt spaniens
ein jahr später nimmt der bahnhof kann
frank seinen betrieb wieder auf doch da
ist der zweite weltkrieg bereits in
vollem gange viele juden und
widerstandskämpfer die aus
nazi-deutschland in richtung süden
fliehen nehmen die route über kann frank
in umgekehrter richtung schickt franco
kriegswichtige rohstoffe und güter nach
deutschland um hitlers kriegsmaschinerie
am laufen zu halten
tonnenweise eisenerz für die
waffenproduktion gelangt über kann frank
nach deutschland
[Musik]
als die nazis im zweiten weltkrieg
frankreich über fehlen wurde kann frank
zu einem bedeutenden bahnhof für
jüdische flüchtlinge die aus frankreich
nach spanien wollten
in umgekehrter richtung mussten die
deutschen debatte um gold aus spanien
über frankreich ins deutsche reich zu
schaffen
der bahnhof ist auch ein tummelplatz für
spione und agenten verschiedener
kriegsparteien
[Applaus]
diese bahnlinie war sehr wichtig um
südfrankreich mit dem rest der welt zu
verbinden von hier aus gingen auch
versorgungsgüter und informationen an
die französische résistance
es gab auch spionagemissionen bei denen
mutige junge frauen dokumente nach
spanien sprudelten von wo sie dann an
die briten weiter gegeben wurden
im verlauf des zweiten weltkrieges
nutzen komischerweise immer mehr
nazigrößen die linie um sich aus dem
staub zu machen als der untergang des
dritten reichs 1945 nicht mehr
aufzuhalten ist flüchten sie in scharen
über die pyrenäen
manche mit kiloweise raub gold im gepäck
[Musik]
fast der einzige weg von frankreich nach
spanien und von dort weiter mit einem
schiff nach wohin auch immer führt über
kein frank das heißt man musste in
cannes frank aus dem zug aussteigen und
durch den bahnhof gehen
das haben auch viele schlechte menschen
so gemacht die sich nach südamerika
absetzen
in zweifel
nach dem krieg verirren sich nur noch
wenige internationale passagiere nach
kann frank der prachtbau verwahrlost
langsam
42 jahre nach seiner feierlichen
eröffnung wird der bahnhof schließlich
ganz geschlossen
so bedeutend die bahnstrecke auf war sie
waren nie profitabel
1970 kam es zu einem zugunglück bei dem
eine der brücken zerstört wurde sie
wurde niemals wieder aufgebaut das war
eine art vorwand dafür dass man die
strecke verfallen ließ denn zu der zeit
wurde das fliegen immer billiger das
straßennetz wurde besser die lastwagen
wurden besser und es gab einfach mehr
alternativen zu dieser schwierigen
strecke
seit den siebziger jahren hält kein zug
mehr in cannes frank und das juwel von
einst verfällt
[Musik]
heute zieht der imposante bau wieder
vermehrt touristen an
[Musik]
viele reisende wollen diesen wunderbaren
bahnhof besuchen es ist beinahe rührend
zu sehen dass menschen so hart an etwas
arbeitet 'nen neueste technologie und
infrastruktur nutzen und nichts dann
jemals richtig funktionierte dann wurde
er sich selbst überlassen und jetzt
gammelt vor sich hin
eines tages wird er wieder eröffnet wir
hatten das angebot den bahnhof für
stattliche 27 millionen euro zu sanieren
und einen neuen auf der anderen seite
dazu zu bauen außerdem sollen in der
umgebung wohnungen entstehen das ist die
zukunft
[Musik]
der warnung von kann frank blickt auf
eine bewegte vergangenheit zurück opfer
täter schmuggler spione sie alle haben
zum mythos dieses seltsamen ortes
beigetragen
und wer weiß möglicherweise ist die
geschichte dieses prachtvollen bahnhofs
ja doch noch nicht zu ende
etwa 3500 kilometer weiter östlich auf
der kola halbinsel nahe der norwegischen
grenze liegt ein verlassenes
industriegelände
[Musik]
eingerahmt von sem steht hier inmitten
der arktischen tundra eine ansammlung
baufällige gebäude
weit und breit ist keine menschenseele
zu sehen nur einige polar hasen hoppeln
durch den schutt
die kola halbinsel ist sehr abgelegen
nördlich des polarkreises
zwischen den beton ruinen stapeln sich
müll und bauschutt
in der mitte des gebäudekomplexes klafft
ein riesiges loch als hätte es eine
explosion gegeben
all diese verfallenen häuser das war
hier los war das so eine art
konzentrationslager oder eine
militärbasis
was ist an diesem abgelegenen flecken
erde im äußersten nordwesten russlands
passiert und warum ist der
gebäudekomplex aufgegeben worden
[Musik]
in den 1960 er jahren liefern sich die
sowjetunion um die vereinigten staaten
einen erbitterten rüstungs und
technologie wettlauf
[Musik]
beide wollen als erste ins all und vor
allem im nuklearen wettrüsten nicht
zurückfallen
dabei geht es auch um
naturwissenschaftliche forschung etwa im
bereich der geologie wie sieht die erde
unter ihrer oberfläche aus und wie
kommen wir dorthin
um heute in die erde zu schauen nutzen
wir seismische wellen wir lösen eine
explosion auf der erdoberfläche aus und
beobachten dann wie die schockwellen
eindringen und reflektiert werden
dadurch können die strukturen erkennen
aber wie genau sehen die aus
in den 60er und 70er jahren waren die
menschen fasziniert vom aufbau der erde
man wollte herausfinden ob man durch die
erdkruste also die oberste erdschicht
bis in den weicheren mantel hinein
bohren konnte das ganze glich einem
unterirdischen wettlauf ins all wer kann
als erstes am tiefsten bohren
[Musik]
diese gebäude waren teil eines
außergewöhnlichen projekts das die
ideologischen geheimnisse der erde
lüften sollte
die sogenannte super tiefe cola bohrung
se 3
unter diesem rostigen etwa 22 zentimeter
großen stahl deckel liegt der eingang in
die unterwelt
zugleich markiert er einen triumph der
sowjets über die usa
in den 60er jahren begannen die usa mit
einem projekt namens moko sie wollten
die kruste durchbohren sie kamen nicht
weit hinten aber eine menge
vor der insel guadeloupe westlich von
mexiko bohren us-geologen etwa 180 meter
tief in den meeresboden
allerdings in einer wassertiefe von 3500
metern
[Musik]
die russen jedoch wollen mehr als
viermal so tief kommen ihr ziel eine 15
kilometer tiefe bohrung
und dann kamen 1970 die russin mit ihrem
super tiefenbohrloch
bohrungen in solchen breiten haben einen
entscheidenden vorteil
die halbinsel kola liegt in einem gebiet
mit sehr sehr alter erdkruste das ist
wichtig denn wenn man dort tiefer bohrt
steigt die temperatur weniger schnell an
das heißt man kann tiefer bohren ohne
dass es zu heiß wird
[Musik]
werden die russen es schaffen tiefer zu
bohren als je ein mensch zuvor
[Musik]
1965 erfolgt der erste spatenstich für
die anlage
ab mai 1970 wird gebohrt
für die sowjets geht es nicht bloß darum
die usa zu überflügeln das wiederum
geologische daten zu gewinnen und um
bodenschätze
die abgelegene kola halbinsel ist dafür
der ideale ort
das ist dort schon ziemlich abgelegen
alle materialien und alle spezialisten
mussten erst dorthin geschafft werden
aber diese auch jetzt hatten oft
bewiesen dass sie das können sie wussten
wie man infrastruktur und große komplexe
anlagen am ende der welt aufbaut
kg nesterenko ist ein russischer
ingenieur und kennt sich mit dem kohl am
bohrloch bestens aus
das bohren des schachts war hier sehr
schwierig ich hatte vorher noch nie ein
solches loch gebohrt und keiner konnte
einem sagen wie man das macht
[Musik]
das erste problem auf das die ingenieure
stoßen ergibt sich aus der physik die
immensen drehmomente in einem nicht
perfekt lot rechten bohrloch machen eine
rotation des mehrere hundert tausend
kilogramm schweren rohrstrang es fast
unmöglich
die sowjet ingenieure müssen neue wege
gehen sie entwickeln bohrkerne in holt
zylinder form
beim bohren hat man eine baumkrone die
sich dreht man crest schlamm und andere
sachen nach unten damit sie sich weiter
dreht das ding frisst sich durch das
gestein in der mitte ist der burgherren
aus dem kann man rückschlüsse über den
aufbau der erde ziehen
je tiefer desto mehr schwierigkeiten
ergeben sich
je tiefer man wird desto schwieriger
wird es das gestänge bleibt stecken die
temperaturen steigen stark an roter der
fels verhält sich anders als erwartet
damals waren das kolossale
technologische erkenntnisse
wir mussten jedes problem direkt an ort
und stelle regeln und das trotz der
typischen schwierigkeiten die man im
norden ohnehin immer hat wie zum
beispiel kurze sommer kälte und
abgeschiedenheit
[Musik]
mehr als zehn jahre lang treiben die
sowjets ihren 200 tonnen schweren rohre
apparat in der post
untergebracht ist er in einem grippe
nordturm
jeden monat stoßen sie etwa 60 meter
tiefer in die erde koste vor
rund 40 kilometer bohrgestänge
verschleißen im laufe der zeit durch
hitze und reibung doch trotz aller
widrigkeiten treiben die ingenieure dem
bohrer zwölf kilometer tief in die erde
und machen das bohrloch in cola damit
zum tiefsten der welt
1983 erreichte die bohrungen eine tiefe
von zwölf kilometern
das war weltrekord was für eine
unfassbare strecke wenn man darüber
nachdenkt die nachricht über die rekord
bohrung verbreitet sich wie ein
lauffeuer und führt zu abenteuerlichen
gerüchten
nachdem sie so tief in die erde gebohrt
hatten kamen gerüchte über ein
angebliches tor zur hölle auf wenn man
ein mikrofon runter ließe und genau
hinhörte könnte man menschen schreien
hören
das war natürlich kompletter nonsens
aber die tatsache dass das soll auch so
tief war regte die fantasie der menschen
an
die bohrarbeiten werden bis zu einer
tiefe von über 12.000 metern fortgesetzt
dann stehen die bohrer für ein jahr
still
was desaströse folgen hat als die
arbeiten 1984 wieder aufgenommen werden
bricht das bohrgestänge fast fünf
kilometer bohrgestänge müssen im loch
zurückgelassen werden wenn man so tief
in die erdkruste burg ist man naturgemäß
kilometer weit von der oberfläche
entfernt und man bohrt immer tiefer und
tiefer wenn man dann den burg
herausnimmt und anschließend wieder in
das gleiche loch rein will ist das sehr
schwierig das ist so als würde man eine
ganze kamel karawane durch ein nadelöhr
fädeln wollen die uhr krone kann stecken
bleiben oder das bohrgestänge brechen
und in diesem fall sind tausende meter
bohrgestänge verloren
die ingenieure staaten eine neue bohrung
an einer abzweigung in über sieben
kilometern tiefe
fünf jahre später haben sie schließlich
die rekord endtiefe von 12.200
62 metern erreicht doch in dieser
immensen tiefe wird das weiter bohren
praktisch unmöglich
die sowjets stellten fest dass das
gestein in dieser tiefe ganz anders ist
als gedacht
je tiefer man runter geht desto heißer
wird es und je heißer es wird desto
stärker wird der bohrer belastet zudem
wird das gestein selbst weiß es hat dort
eine konsistenz so ähnlich wie knete
[Musik]
angesichts der enormen temperaturen in
der tiefe ziehen die russen die
reißleine die arbeiten auf der kola
halbinsel werden eingestellt
obwohl sich ihre zielvorgabe von 15
kilometern tiefe nicht erreichen konnten
haben die sowjets dennoch unser wissen
über die geologischen strukturen der
erdkruste entscheidend vorangebracht
zu ihrer großen überraschung fanden sie
tiefenbohrloch sehr viel wasser viel
tiefer als das grundwasser ist und auch
jenseits möglicher meerwasser effekte
zudem waren sie überrascht dass es
immense mengen wasserstoff im gestein
gab die forscher vermuten dass das
wasser da unten so stark komprimiert
wird dass es wasserstoff freisetzt und
sie gewinnen noch weitere erkenntnisse
wir stießen in einer tiefe von sieben
bis 8000 metern auf ehemaliges leben
eine bestimmte art von bakterien die
mikro fossilien wie man dort unten
gefunden hatte waren uralte einzellige
organismen die forscher waren überrascht
dass es so etwas in dieser tiefe noch
gibt
2005 stellt russland keine mittel für
das projekt mehr bereit und gibt die
anlage schließlich auf die super tiefe
cola bohrung se 3 hat fast ein drittel
des baltischen schiltz durchbohrt noch
heute ist sie das tiefste künstliche
noch der welt
[Musik]
inzwischen verdeckt ein rostiger
kanaldeckel den eingang
wer auf diesen kleinen eisendeckel steht
weiß vielleicht nicht dass unter ihm
zwölf kilometer wissen über die vorgänge
in der erdkruste stecken
schon faszinierend dass so ein bizarrer
ort einblicke in das innerste unseres
planeten bietet die insel
mehr als 8000 kilometer entfernt im
süden kaliforniens liegt der sollten sie
kaliforniens größter sie ist fast 1000
quadratkilometer groß sehr flach und
liegt mitten in der colorado wüste
das ist ein besonderer ort in der wüste
kaliforniens
156 kilometer langer see mitten in der
wildnis
im nordosten des sees ragen verwitterte
holzpfosten als dem wasser ein altes
dorf von wüstensand bedeckt der geruch
von fisch kadavern erfüllt den
gespenstischen ort
tore trostlosigkeit alles verfällt es
ist wie auf einem friedhof
ein allein stehendes gebäude trotzdem
herrschen wüsten bedingungen seiner
traurigen überreste zeugen von der
geschichte dieses orts
hier unterhalb der wüstenwind auch
bröckelige beton straßen frei
halb verschüttete bunker und fundamente
lange verschwundene häuser
außerdem zwei jeweils etwa
1200 meter lange flugpisten
an der küste liegen tote fische rum
das hier ist eine der bekanntesten
postapokalyptischen landschaften in den
usa
[Musik]
warum wurde die seltsame anlage einst in
dieser lebensfeindlichen einöde gebaut
und warum wurde sie dann wieder
aufgegeben
[Musik]
im dezember 1944 trifft eine gruppe
handverlesener wissenschaftler auf einem
flugfeld südlich von sorten city ein
sie sind in geheimer mission ihr sie
sollen die atombombe bauen bevor die
nazis ihnen zuvorkommen
während die usa in europa und im pazifik
kriegführen beginnt die gruppe namens z
46 mit ihren streng geheimen tests
[Musik]
ihre mission projekt ypsilon genannt ist
teil des manhattan projekts das den bau
der atombombe mit hochdruck voran treibt
sollten sie wird als eine der haupt
forschungsstätten ausgewählt
sie war ein ideales testgebiet für das
manhattan project aus zwei gründen es
war erstens komplett abgeschieden und
bot daher zweitens völliger
geheimhaltung
die militärbasis steht inmitten einer
rund 80 quadratkilometer großen wüste
was hier passiert bleibt auch hier
selbst heute sind viele akten der anlage
noch immer unter verschluss
leon jessica ist in der gegend zu hause
sein bruder war wachmann auf dem
testgelände
sie haben hier viele versuche gemacht
aber das war ziemlich geheim sogar sehr
geheimen
[Musik]
nichts war so anspruchsvoll wie das
manhattan projekt in bezug auf
koordinierung zusammenarbeit integration
der verschiedenen industrieunternehmen
der wissenschaft und des militärs
die tests auf dem marineflieger
stützpunkt werden von hier aus
koordiniert
deckname sein baby ein idealer ort um
die sprengkraft und flugbahn
verschiedener bomben zu testen
wenn du die stärkste bombe der welt
abwerfen willst musst du absolut sicher
sein dass sie auch präzise trifft
die us atombomben sollen bei einer
boeing b 29 super fortress aus
abgeworfen werden
sie sind so konstruiert dass sie 600
meter über dem boden explodieren die
beobachter teams haben genau 43 sekunden
zeit um den abwurf zu beurteilen bevor
die bombe ins wasser fällt
zusätzlich werden daten wie druck
temperatur erschütterungen und
beschleunigung ermittelt
[Musik]
wir haben in der wüste gibt es kaum
wolken wenn man eine bombe bei tage
abwirft sind die sichtbedingungen also
ideal
dieses ziel darin etwa zweieinhalb
kilometern haben sie versucht zu treffen
obwohl das ziel nur 60 meter von der
basis entfernt ist ist es für die
bomberpiloten aus der luft nur schwer
auszumachen
aber die piloten müssen ihre explosive
fracht präzise und aus großer höhe
abwerfen sonst riskieren sie im
ernstfall ihr leben denn die detonation
welle kann einen bomber sonst leicht vom
himmel holen
1944 und 45 werden etliche ballistische
tests durchgeführt denn selbst kleinste
veränderungen in der form oder länge der
bombe oder des herodes können das
flugverhalten beeinflussen
in schortens ii wurden fünf tonnen
schwere beton gefüllte übungsbomben
abgeworfen und auch prototypen der
hiroshima bombe wurden
höchstwahrscheinlich hier getestet
[Musik]
auch attrappen der fährt man atombombe
werden hier getestet bis auf das
fehlende nuklearmaterial gleichen sie
exakt der bombe die am 8 august 1945
nagasaki in schutt und asche legte
einige flugzeuge waren mit automatischen
kameras ausgestattet so konnte man genau
sehen wo die bomben einschlugen man
konnte die abwurf stelle auf der karte
markieren und die bomben mitunter sogar
bergen
die beteiligten ingenieure testen immer
wieder und aller elektronischen
komponenten funktionieren und ob diese
ganze technik auch wirklich zur
gewaltigsten explosion führen wird die
die welt je gesehen hat
alles musste genauso ablaufen wie die
ingenieure und wissenschaftler es
geplant hatten
[Musik]
mehr als 120 übungsbomben werden übers
ottens ebase abgeworfen einige der
attrappen flogen anders als geplant und
verfehlten ihre ziele
noch heute liegen vier der gigantischen
bomben tief im wüstensand vergraben
[Musik]
eine von denen es direkt auf einem
tennisplatz eingeschlagen was nicht so
gut ankam aber ich schätze nur so lernt
man
bei den ersten übungsabläufe gerät die
fed men bombe noch heftig ins trudeln
die ingenieure und sollten sie ihn
müssen das design der bundes verändern
sie konstruieren einen kasten adliges
heck mit acht flossen
dieses california parachute genannte
design hält die flugbahn stabil was die
treffsicherheit verbessert
ohne die ihre dynamischen tests sind
sollten sie wären die ersten
nuklearwaffen tests in leitzins im juli
1945 nicht möglich gewesen und ohne sie
wären little boy und fährt man nicht
einen monat später über hiroshima und
nagasaki detoniert
ohne sie wären nicht hunderttausende
menschen auf einen schlag getötet worden
und das japanische kaiserreich hätte
möglicherweise nicht kapituliert
sorgen sie war für das manhattan projekt
sehr wichtig
angesichts des immensen aufwands der in
manhattan project getrieben wurde wäre
es ein unding gewesen eine bombe zu
bauen die das ziel nicht trifft
nach ende des zweiten weltkriegs wird
sollten cbs weiter als testgelände
genutzt
in den fünfziger und sechziger jahren
jedoch avanciert die nahegelegene stadt
sorgten city zu einem beliebten
ferienort was sich nicht gut mit der
militärischen geheimhaltung verträgt
1971 wird dies ottens ebase schließlich
geschlossen und den verfall überlassen
heute haben sand und salzige luft die
letzten gebäude fast vollständig
aufgefressen
nur wenig weiß darauf hin dass hier
einst eine wichtige militärische
forschungsstätte der usa war die den
ausgang des zweiten weltkrieges
entscheidend beeinflusst hat
es gibt keine gedenktafel kein denkmal
nichts was auf die bedeutung des orts
hinweist
sollten sie bis ist heute ein mahnmal
für die gefahren der nuklearen
aufrüstung und die folgen von krieg
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite des atlantiks etwa
50 kilometer südlich der belgischen
hauptstadt brüssel legt eine
industriebrache am ufer der song
[Musik]
wie ein monolith thront der schäbige
betonturm in der verlassenen landschaft
sein durchmesser am boden beträgt 60
meter seiner höhe 100 metern
in gleicher form einer riesigen beton
kathedrale mit einer runden öffnung zum
himmel absolut eindrucksvoll ein
wahnsinns anblick
eigentlich ganz schön mit seinen
fließenden formen
am boden hat der turmbau zahlreiche
öffnungen und hohlräume
der innenraum gleicht einem unfertigen
bienenstock voller galander holzlatten
und moos bewachsene wasser verteilen
doch was ist das geheimnis dieser
verwunschenen gewaltigen turmruine warum
wurde sie aufgegeben
1921 ist die wallonische stadt charleroi
ein zentrum der belgischen industrie
doch nach der vierjährigen deutschen
besatzung während des ersten weltkriegs
kämpfen viele unternehmen ums überleben
obwohl belgien neutral war überfiel
deutschland das kleine land 1914 und
beutete seine industrie rücksichtslos
aus
historiker sprechen später von der
schändung belgiens
um der wirtschaft wieder auf die beine
zu helfen warum die belgier in der stadt
hama das riesige kohlekraftwerk em
bei der energieerzeugung kommen häufig
dampf- gebieten zum einsatz um dampf zu
erzeugen braucht man wasser dass dabei
sehr heiß wird will man mehr dann fühlt
man dieses heiße wasser ab und
produziert neuen dampf
das kohlekraftwerk im januar ist in den
20er jahren eines der größten europas
[Musik]
sein wahrzeichen ist der monumentale
kühlturm hier wird das wasser
heruntergekühlt um durch
kohleverbrennung neuen dampf zu erzeugen
[Musik]
ein kühlturm erkennt man wegen seiner
besonderen form schon von weiter
flüchtig man nennt diese körper hyper
beruhigt sie haben am boden einen großen
durchmesser verjüngen sich in der mitte
und öffnen sich wieder etwas nach oben
wegen dieser form strömt die warme luft
durch den turm wird an der schmaleren
stelle beschleunigt zieht wir in einem
schornstein mehr kalte luft von unten an
und erzeugt dadurch die gewünschte kühn
[Musik]
im kühlturm forscher konnten dank der
charakteristischen architektur
rekordverdächtiger
2200 kubikmeter wasser pro minute
gekühlt werden
[Musik]
die hütter wohld form von kühltürmen
ermöglicht einen äußerst effektiven
wärmetransport zwischen dem heißen
wasser und der aufsteigenden luft
deswegen hat dieses design ja auch die
zeiten überdauert es ist eine klassische
und effektive art der kühlung
doch trotz seiner simplen funktionsweise
der bau des turms war eine technische
herausforderung
denn bei der hypo kolorit form geht es
auch darum den aufwendigen baukörper
möglichst leicht zu halten
so große fließende und schöne formen zu
schaffen ist eine ziemliche
herausforderung
jeder der schon mal an einer
töpferscheibe gearbeitet hat weiß wie
schwierig das ist zumal in solchen
dimensionen
normalerweise verwendet man dazu ein
schalungen und gussformen doch mit
zunehmender höhe muss man die gussformen
immer wieder anpassen um die runde form
hinzubekommen
außerdem muss man den beton in großer
höhe gießen und das alles in einer zeit
als es noch keine computer gab man hat
nur papier und bleistift rechnet sich
aus wie das gehen kann und dann wird
gebaut
1921 geht das kraftwerk ans netz
durch eine zentrale öffnung sprudelt
heißes wasser aus der maschine in den
kühlturm
in hunderten flachen drinnen das
aufgefangen um die oberfläche des
wassers zu vergrößern und dadurch den
abkühlung prozess zu beschleunigen
das das prinzip beruht auf der tatsache
dass heiße luft weniger dicht und daher
leichter ist kalte luft wiederum es
dichter und daher schwerer das heißt die
heiße luft steigt in diesen firmen nach
oben während die kalte am boden bleibt
durch die form des turms entsteht zudem
eine besondere aerodynamik die den
kamineffekt unterstützt
in den zwischen tricks jahren ist das
kraftwerk ein motor für die industrielle
entwicklung belgiens
1940 jedoch wird berlin weder vom
deutschland besetzt und die besatzer
zapfen die energie für ihre zwecke hat
nach dem krieg versorgt das kraftwerk
berlin weiter mit energie und ist mitte
der 70er jahre haupt stromlieferant für
den großraum schal rohr
doch die tage der anlage sind da bereits
gezählt
denn in den wasserrinnen des kühlturms
lauert eine gefahr
in einem ton ist es warm und feucht und
diese bedingungen bieten einen idealen
nährboden für die legionärskrankheit die
tödlich sein kann
trotzdem ist das kohlekraftwerk für
dekaden am netz aber das ist nicht das
einzige problem
das kohlekraftwerk stößt alarmierend
hohe kohlendioxid mengen aus
einem bericht zufolge ist die anlage für
zehn prozent des gesamten kohlendioxid
ausstoßes belgiens verantwortlich im
jahr 2006 startet greenpeace eine
landesweite protestkampagne ein jahr
später gehen die lichter im kraftwerk
für immer aus seitdem es die
kontaminierte anlage verweist und rottet
vor sich hin
heute zieht der endzeit charme der
industrieruine vor allem fotografen und
andere freunde monumentale architektur
an
jahrzehntelang wurde die anlage nur
durch die ingenieurs brille betrachtet
jetzt sehen viele wie schön sie ist
darum erhält man die anlage
heute ist das fast 100 jahre alte
bauwerk mit seinen ikonischen kühlturm
ein zeugnis belgischer industrie und
architekturgeschichte
[Musik]
ich persönlich liebe diese mathematische
und strukturelle perfektion dieser
türken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen
in diesen verfallenen bauten sind die
echos der geschichte hörbar sie könnten
von krieg und terror vom erfindergeist
und menschlichem streben nach
fortschritt
[Musik]